let's bring in a dr. Mehmet Oz host of
the dr. Oz Show he's been gene joining
us every day during the pandemic dr. oz
it is terrific that the comfort is now
in the New York City area yesterday they
said it was 70,000 tons of I Love New
York but they're going to be serving
people who don't have kovat but here's
the problem it just takes one case of
covin 19 on that ship to potentially
turn it into something that we've seen
in cruise lines doesn't it you're right
but they're pretty careful about this I
think if first of all it's a great
example of how the federal government
can play a positive role from just from
the division of having a ship Navy ship
come into port to help you out it race
raises morale and there are risks no
question about some likova thinking
coming in but they're meticulously
monitoring everybody that's the whole
point of separate facilities for copa90
patients and and folks who are having
the ailment and there's another hospital
fueled hospital that's in Central Park
built by Samaritan's Purse that's only
taking cope with 19 patients so we're
pretty careful about this and their ways
of screening it as soon as any symptoms
are demonstrated at least they're in
that setting you can rapidly change that
it's all a positive from my perspective
but the big issue is the testing they
have to test in that hospital and the
president spoke about this yesterday
we've done a million tests now in this
country but that's this solution that
all of us need because without that
testing you just don't know so the
commander of the comfort doesn't know
that hospital drunken doesn't know the
governor's don't know and the president
doesn't know if you don't test people
adequately yeah dr. oz it's funny you
mentioned that because the the president
yesterday in his press briefing he
pulled out one of those rapid tests that
are being distributed starting today
listen to what he said if you missed it
at home today we reached a historic
milestone in our war against the corona
virus over 1 million Americans have now
been tested more than any other country
by far not even close and tested
accurately as the president mentioned
today the United States hit more than 1
million samples tested a number that no
other country has reached we're now
testing nearly 100,000
samples a day also a level that no other
country has reached dr. Ives I want you
to respond to that and also we were
talking Brian mentioned the map of you
can see where people the fever's are
going down why is that if you have
doctor foul Qi saying the peak is going
to be in a week or two what do we
believe is it are we getting better are
we going to see a peak in a week well I
think both are true the reality is the
fever comes first the person then sort
of struggles for a couple days then they
finally go to the hospital in New York
City because there's no room we'll do
everything we can to keep you out of the
hospital you finally get admitted a week
of ten days later it shows up a
statistic that the governor can show and
say analyst and here's the data on
hospital admissions or even mortalities
which will like give it another week or
two down the road because you don't go
to the hospital and die you go to the
ICU from there and then you get
intimated then you struggle then you've
got forbid you die so the numbers are
all make perfect sense I think Brian
might be maybe it could be an
epidemiologist going forward because
he's right what we're seeing now is it
is a slow decline of the rise that we
were seeing so we're no longer we
doubling numbers that people go into the
hospital every two days an ounce every
six days and where that should peak
based on the Chinese data over the next
two weeks but of all the numbers we
follow the most important number is what
the president just said a million tests
done that number means we can finally
decide in a targeted way exactly what
we're going to do it's just we can take
sniper shots at problems rather than
having to blast everything with a
shotgun that gives us so much more
opportunity to correct the problems
we're facing yeah that box we got to get
that box out so we get a quick results
on these tests you don't need the
reagents so let's talk about immunity
how do we build immunity in our system
to kill the virus early what could you
tell us about examples of progress their
treatment so I'll go through this list
there's there's ten before four
different categories I'm gonna leave
immunizations to this side although I'm
very happy that Johnson and Johnson got
a big government contractor to get to
really scale this up we have a bunch of
companies doing this god bless them all
they all work in slightly different ways
and I'm very confident that some of
these will pan out for next year but
what do we do in the meantime so here's
four different categories the first
thing is you build up your innate immune
system and there's a couple ways of
doing it I've got some lists you'll put
them up in the screen
if the first item that I'm going to
point out and and this is critical is
that you can enhance the immune system
with convalescent plasma therapy which
did you give immunoglobulins antibodies
made by someone who recovered into
someone who's deathly ill and that seems
to jumpstart them there was a nice
article in JAMA one of our biggest
medical journals showing four out of
five patients did really well with this
program four or five people who are you
know these people are all dying
basically and the fifth person is still
alive that's good news they're not
interesting ly high dose vitamin C might
play a role here which is one of the
reasons we think vitamin C helps to
shorten a duration of it of a common
cold so it's probably worth considering
at high doses and new york hospitals and
other facilities are testing it but the
jury's still out by the way I'm going to
go through this list it's all gonna be
on foxnews.com I'll put it on my social
media feeds as well there's a lot more
it's a hundred different ideas out there
that are being tried next up you want to
prevent the virus if your immune system
is not strong enough you don't want the
virus to get into the cell so how do you
block it from getting into the cell well
that's where hydroxychloroquine plays a
role we've been talking about it a lot
that's the the malaria drug we believe
that's one of the mechanisms by which it
might play a role
I actually correspondent with did the
alt position leading the trials in
France you know they're gonna have 500
patients on the combination with their
zip through mice and the z-pak this week
and he's if he could he'd add zinc
because he believes hide those zinc
which could potentially eight the action
and that's something you can do at home
frankly you take a little dose now if
you desire but doesn't we don't have
evidence of that but hide those if you
get ill might make sense the third major
area is if the virus if your immune
system can catch it and it penetrates
into your cells but then the question is
how you block its replication how do you
stop it from from doing damage there's a
butler REM des aveer is a good example
al open or rid of there these are
promising therapies they some of them
have not shown if efficacy to the degree
we've desired but these were designed
for other illnesses like HIV and Ebola
and now they're being utilized in a more
aggressive fashion in these different
trials because in theory they should
work and finally you can block the or
the over response of our inflammatory
system the complement storm so to speak
where the body just can't keep up with
the virus and there are two medications
I put on here which are both still
experimental but there's a bunch of
others that work in this area
remember if we have a drug that works
for people at horrible infections or bad
cancers to block the overt response of
the body well you could use those same
drugs for coronavirus for coke Ovid 19
so that's our hope and one last idea
that I quickly ran by losartan which is
a medication it's a blood pressure
medication it works at the same receptor
that this virus uses the sneaked into
your cells jury's still out we don't
want people going off those meds because
it turns out they may actually help you
by blocking the virus from getting in so
those trials are getting FDA approved
products we'll have to show that they
work but that might be an opportunity as
well sure so dr. oz the medical
community is looking at all these
various drugs and I know they use some
supercomputers to try to figure out what
drugs might work with this particular
version of kovat 19 but let's say
somebody's watching right now in Detroit
and they've got Cova they've been tested
and they've got it does does every
doctor in America right now know these
various drugs that could potentially
help their patient no categorically not
the one drug that's gotten mindshare of
the physician community and I know this
cuz I've spoken there's so many doctors
in so many states is is the de
chloroquine hydroxychloroquine
especially when combined with as if from
Ison and and part of that's because it's
been elevated to a conversation point by
discussions of our public officials and
the medical community respects that
they're probably safe enough that we're
not doing any harm in is they as the
governor of Kansas told me recently he
said you go to war with the army you
have and this is all we have right now
but some of these other products have
been used clinically in other settings
as I mentioned low start and family of
drugs to blood pressure drugs and those
drugs therefore could be rapidly
transitioned over it's because doctors
know how to use them they know how to
use them safely
if there's any clue they may be
beneficial in the right patient we'll
start the experiment but with dr.
thought you said is right you want to
simultaneously test these and when the
president insisted that there be
clinical testing in the meantime pushed
the FDA to approve these products for
doctors to prescribe that was the right
move you know trust that they might work
verify that they work with clinical
trials in the meantime don't hold the
hands but don't hold doctors back I
should say don't tie the hands that
from doing the most for their patients
if you're a patient you gets conferred
19 it is worth asking your doctor about
any of the products on this list
especially the hydroxy clear alone we
don't know for sure but that the
chloroquine is defective
you might try it all right dr. oz Brian
was interviewing a girl in her 20s who
had it and she was so frustrated she
called the hotline waited an hour and 45
minutes then they told her they'd call
her back with the test and then she
called again she was on hold for a while
and then she they said you need to call
your physician and get a test she called
her physician and he said no that's not
what you're supposed to do I know we're
all figuring this out right now and
there are a lot of unknowns but when
will we be at a point as a country where
we have all the drugs we need we have
all the masks that we need we have all
the supplies for the hospital we have
the ventilators when will we get to that
point well you were kind enough to ask
my question of the president yesterday
because it's all driven by testing and
I'll give you an example why that's so
important right now if I order a test
and this is actually this is true all
over the country I can probably wait
five six days to get the results back
now imagine going to a hospital as a
patient you're not sure yet a fever and
a cough you feel tired classic signs but
you don't know what that means you get
admitted they order the test for five to
seven days you stay in an isolation room
with all the nurses wasting caps gowns
masks because it turns out you didn't
have kovin 19 because most of the time a
test comes back negative
now all those resources thrown away
because we didn't have a test
likewise our ability to target people
and make sure the right ones are a
proper I've given priority to get to the
IC or get intubated is wasted when we
don't know for sure what we're dealing
with so once we have the testing all the
other opportunities become all mented
because we'll use our resources more
efficiently in the ventilator I do
believe that by the middle of April
we'll have GM and other companies making
enough that that problem goes away
I hope so so we you have talked more
than anybody else about
hydroxychloroquine and you want to get
the results of this study so is one way
to get the results of this study if I
can say this effectively is the people
that are on it now for whatever it's
lupus or with everything else can you
find out how this virus is acting in
them and quickly get their record from
Medicare and Medicaid because it's paid
for by them and see how it's acting get
the results of that study and see if it
could be mass-produced from from coast
to coast you know that is such a
brilliant idea the Chinese actually did
it well the reason they began using this
drug as part of their routine in China
is they've looked at a hospital that had
a very big violent cases and it turns
out that none of the patients who are on
the the cleric win for their lupus or
their rheumatoid arthritis which is the
reason you'd be on it got cove in
nineteen and conversely none of the
patients who got cope in nineteen had
rheumatoid arthritis or lupus so then
they thought what's the difference well
one there a couple differences obviously
but one of them was this medication use
and that was one of the key clues that
got them moving forward I'm making this
part of their formulators so to speak I
think that is a wonderful concept the
FDA actually
Medicare CMS Seema Verma could do this
immediately rapidly check to see if in
fact is having a protective effect that
would give I think a lot of the medical
community comfort that they weren't
overstretching by reacting to a bunch of
case reports and you know large large
groups of patients being with their data
collected as opposed to a traditional
randomized trial that were more
comfortable acting on so gets amazing
okay with much get forgiving us and up
to date an update on things that are
going on on the cutting edge of medicine
right now because there are patients in
the states of Louisiana and Michigan and
New Jersey it looks like those of the
states that are going to be impacted
next sir we thank you very much for
joining us live